foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be discussing some very
exciting news regarding House of the
dragon's second season I want to make
sure you're up to date on all of the new
information that has been releasing this
week now before I get into all of that I
have to let all of you know about this
new fun game I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video gemstone
Legends gemstone Legends is an epic RPG
game full of Adventures and tactical
battles gemstone has a 4.6 star rating
on Android and almost 5 stars on iOS you
can download and try the game for free
by using the link in the description or
scanning the QR code on your screen to
team up with me and get an amazing
starter pack the RPG enthusiasts who
made this game really made sure to
include something for everyone when
designing this game they combined
several different genres into one you've
got the puzzle Style game but you also
get to collect Heroes with over 200
characters from 8 different factions the
heroes are ranked in tears from common
to uncommon and then rare epic and
legendary now the coolest part for me is
that all of the heroes have their own
unique skill set making each battle more
strategic plus there's dragons and I
know all of you House of the Dragons
fans will love that you can even bring
your own dragon to battles and fight in
player versus player mode with other
Dragon Riders to compete in the Guild
Wars complete daily weekly and monthly
missions and be sure to join the Discord
channel to stay up to date on all new
content that will be coming out you can
find me in game under the name talking
Thrones download the game for free now
on both Android and iOS devices by using
the link in the description or scanning
the QR code on your screen and as a
starter you'll receive 500 000 coins 300
gems 10 Mana Elixir 10 hailing Elixir
and the 4 star hero aneki worth of fifty
dollars you don't want to miss out on
this offer once again I have to thank
gemstone Legends for sponsoring today's
video good luck and I'll see you all all
of you there
all right now let's look at the new
updates for House of the dragon's second
season in my latest video I showed you a
new article that revealed HBO is looking
for new actors for their Infamous blood
and cheese scene last week we found out
they are looking for young actors to
stand in for aegon and Helena's Sons now
for those of you who aren't familiar
with who blood and cheese are let me
show you a video from Game of Thrones
history and lore
two men were found
one was a former gold cloak the other a
rat catcher in the red keep who knew all
its secrets history remembers them only
as blood and cheese
one night Queen Helena entered the Royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand they told her that a debt was owed
a son for a son blood and cheese
demanded she choose which Sun would be
ripped from her forever
Queen Elena pleaded with the man to kill
her instead but they refused weeping
Helena named her younger son Melo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
perhaps because the older boy was King
aegon's first born son and Heir you hear
that little boy she's whispered to the
younger son
your mama wants you dead then blood
struck off the older boy's head with a
single blow when the gods burst in they
found Queen Helena still screaming
clasping her dead son's body to her mad
with grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
either aegon or anira could live at the
end but not both
it describes what we should see happen
in the next season this will be one of
the most shocking scenes in House of the
dragon and like I said HBO is already
looking for young actors for this scene
so it seems like we will definitely see
it happen in The Following Season well
according to rodanian intelligence HBO
is looking for another actor who will
fill the role as the character known as
blood according to their Source HBO is
looking for someone who they are naming
Boris who is easily identifiable as
blood of the blood and cheese Duo now
keep in mind they like to alter the
names during the filming as a way to not
reveal exactly what they're doing it
says Boris is a large tough and very
tall man he's also a man who's willing
to do violence without hesitation the
actor for blood is also encouraged to
have some comedic chops earlier they
also reported on someone who sounded
like cheese in all audition video for a
Charlie C thus it looks like we have
early casting info on blood and cheese
or a Boris and Charlie as the code names
would have it in the audition Boris and
Charlie seem to be seeking a royal
Prince to kidnap and are sneaking into
what sounds like the red key however
their intent on kidnapping might be a
misdirection as casting scripts often
differ from the real ones that end up in
the final draft now if you go down in
the description of this video you can
follow their link and watch the audition
video for yourself unfortunately I
cannot show you that in my video
otherwise HBO will have it deleted as
well as striking my channel that's
exactly what they did the last time I
showed an audition video for House of
the Dragons first season now the other
casting call is for someone named goon
it will be a series regular who's a snob
very arrogant and aged around 30. the
actor for goon must have horse riding
skills as most of his scenes will be on
Horseback this role is slightly less
obvious than blood as there can be
various options as to who it might be so
as you can see HBO is looking for young
actors around the ages of three or four
as well as older men named Boris and
Charlie I don't know about you but I
definitely believe this is for the blood
and cheese scene it already has me very
excited for what's to come now in other
news we finally have a start date for
when House of the Dragon will begin
filming its second season according to
the film and television industry
Alliance season two of House of the
Dragon will begin filming on March 6 in
Spain in London the show also has listed
Alan Taylor as the Director though we
know from an announcement made last
August that he'll also be serving as an
executive producer remember he will be
stepping in for Miguel sapochnik now
like I've said in many other videos we
will start to learn a lot more
information once filming begins in March
that's when we will learn exactly what
will be happening next season that's
when most of the actors will be on set
filming their scenes soon enough we will
see a significant amount of photos and
videos leaking from the sets as always I
will be here making videos about
everything every step of the way make
sure you subscribe that way you're
always up to date with what's happening
behind the scenes at House of the Dragon
I will also keep you up to date on
everything that's happening with the
other Game of Thrones shows as well as
George RR Martin's The Winds of Winter
for now I want to thank all of you for
watching this video let me know what you
think about all the new information Down
Below have a great day everyone I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
foreign